A super creepy "real-life" Barbie woman monster
thinks she's going to be able to survive on
only sunlight and air
Howdy folks, Trace here for DNews -- Valeria
Lukyanova has had a lot of alterations to
become a real-life Barbie.
It's weird and creepy and gross, but that's
beside the point.
She has now come out as a wanna-be Breatharian.
Breatharian isn't a word she made up, ohhhh
no.
It's from Eastern teachings and centers around
a belief that food and water aren't necessary
to survive...
She seems to want to survive on sunshine and
rainbows!
But she can't.
Humans don't have chlorophyll to help us absorb
energy from light, we get energy from food.
Firstly, while there are studies to show intermittent
fasting might have a benefit in mice, to completely
stop eating is just cray cray. Gandhi fasted
for 21 days, and doctors believe humans can
go, maybe, eight weeks without food -- as
long as we have water.
Biologically, starvation involves a set of
events that have never in history been conquered.
No one has ever gone without food permanently
and survived.
First, the body burns carbs and sugars then
proteins; eventually it will break down its
own muscles to stay alive.
Without food, brain runs on proteins and sugars
broken down within the body, it's an evolutionary
advantage, but the lack of energy causes weakness
and confusion, immune deficiency and irritability.
Once full-on starvation hits, Miss Lukyanova
will have convulsions, hallucinations, muscle
spasms, and chronic diarrhea.
This might take a few weeks... but it is inevitable.
And that's the easy bit.
We can't survive for more than 3-to-5 days
without water.
H2O lubricates our joints, protects our mucous
membranes, regulates body temperature, helps
dissolve minerals into our bloodstream and
flush waste, and keeps the cells and fluids
in our body plump and happy.
A baby in a hot car could die from lack of
fluids in a matter of hours.
Adult humans can survive a bit longer, depending
on their health.
First, they'll experience a lack of saliva
and urine; eventually dry mouth; dry, sunken
eyes; rapid heartbeats; vomiting; and diarrhea.
Less than a week later, during full-blown
dehydration, the human body goes into shock
to protect itself and then dies.
Not having enough to eat is bad enough, attempting
to go without eating and living off "sunlight
and air" is dumb.
Let's say Miss Real-Life Barbie knows all
this, and she's going to sneak the essentials
of life.
What's the minimum she needs to survive?
Medically supervised very-low calorie diets
exist where patients only consume five to
eight hundred calories per day, usually of
a high-nutrient shake or bar.
It must be medically supervised because often
patients produce gallstones and experience
starvation symptoms.
The doctor can monitor and swoop in to save
the person from their lack of diet.
In the 1970s, some obese individuals attempted
a fad diet where they'd only eat 400 calories
a day; many had unexpected heart attacks.
All these plans include lots of water, and
most were tested for 8-12-week weight-loss
plans, not full-time survival.
Even at that low 800-calorie level humans
need a variety of nutrients, amino acids and
food types to satisfy our dietary requirements!
It's not exactly easy to sneak food and still
stay healthy.
There are people who claim to live on a Breatharian
diet, but none have been scrutinized by science.
At least four people who joined the movement
have died.
Long story short, we NEED to eat and drink
to live.
That might be obvious to some humans, but
apparently not all...
Do you think this Barbie girl is living in
a Barbie world?
How do you feel about it?
Tell us down below and be sure to subscribe.
Thanks for watching DNews!